yeah he went to welcome to this video
playing a pool ah yeah not getting
anywhere with my reading simply not
playing well my newest games like the
one before whoo yeah very one-sided
affair and you make far too many
mistakes we need to as always tempting
still tempting
Maji f6 is now the most natural move e5
what why should that be a move that is
even remotely playable it looks terrible
no g5 lets him know a single night age
six
okay so it's canceled
probably four or what do we do here
d3 maybe I don't have a win yet right
like we should have 796 or so I mean
this is all already quite close but
doesn't work yet
might be six I don't know
yeah Queen to h5 Queen f3 those moves I
wonder about f4 if that's if that is the
thing just to like go into punishment
mode maybe let's try try to open up the
fo by force I mean I'm really amazed
that this stamp somehow is not be losing
immediately what he did and it looks
really terrible okay um
push it before it's kind of normal but
hmm already takes me to I mean and that
works I mean where else is he going to
go to a5 probably it's just taking 1v -
yes
I don't know there's no wind somehow Wow
I know I don't see anything special
can maybe take Knight takes bishop g6
and hold this position
what is he trying to do here so it says
something better I mean
rookie heat or something I mean it looks
very ambitious bishop before I don't
know he's taking a lot of time here okay
yeah I mean that's pretty okay I mean it
can be happy that is some I was still in
the game I don't have anything I don't
have anything yet
maybe age form but he's got Queen to e5
I mean it's a double attack
it's really a double attack Queen here
maybe cover five Queen e7 maybe in some
cases it's got 24 though and it's
nothing special I mean
what is that doing 93 okay and it's
thread an age five it's a ticking of
this
and I'm not happy about Queen f2 words I
didn't see anything good I don't have
the porn back yet him
I don't know don't happy about that move
I want is somewhat easier to play
position as the thing when things cover
1 another 97 days somehow escaping all
this I mean the blundering if to see two
great things go really great
what's down to one second it's still all
those moves are good
whoopty for yeah cause he sees
everything I don't know no no I'm not
going to rematch him forget about that
yeah I don't know I mean if I was just
totally atrocious I mean it's like plus
two and I'm not winning but what am I
doing here
and that doesn't even a bad move what is
best castles no my knee five is just
terrible because it weakens the whole
diagonal f7 anyway but not somehow it's
not winning I don't know why that
doesn't wait maybe f4 was wrong it's
possible but I mean the worst thing is
you can just take on b2 maybe this isn't
even good yeah in comparison it's not
good
something like d4 Knight f3 is just you
know why not Knight f3 you might not
play Knight f3 and simply take on aged
six for a complete ruin
we're not playing like an idiot I mean
this is still kind of an initiative but
it's not not convincing yeah Queen
before I see only move but it looks
Queen a choice the threat here was down
he was down to two almost zero
defendant is very well yeah it was a
blunder I was frustrated by at the time
I really I mean it's a bit frustrating
if they give you a winning position
after five moves basically and then you
manage to not win somehow castles in
spell ahem
yeah it's difficult actually to make a
move with black ham this is a problem
Knight f6 I mean that doesn't work that
doesn't work yeah yeah yeah I always
have that problem if they play the
opening like beginner style with e5 I
tend to relax too much and think it wins
by itself but somehow then they make
good moves even though this is really
like I don't know I don't know how bad
that is but it's really bad but then
somehow err they they tend to find good
moves even with a second on the clock it
sometimes works and I don't know I just
relax too much in those situations and
they don't get rid of that somehow that
that problem yeah anyhow next game I
hope to do better thanks for watching